[Musique]
et des milliers de marins ont été coulés, mon cœur leur est
vraiment reconnaissant Churchill a dit
que c'était l'un des pires voyages au
monde et comme je le dis, j'ai le plus grand
respect pour eux,
il suit donc que nous avons pensé
que tout ce qui avait aidé a commencé le réalisateur  et pour
le peuple russe, comme toujours, ils
reçoivent bien certains des endroits où ils
mouraient de faim
et je suis allé dans une Sara et un cimetière
où il n'y a que des monticules de terre où
les habitants sont morts et je les ai en quelque sorte
enterrés ils sont  pas des noms ce ne sont
que des chiffres
il y a eu 27 millions de russes tués
pendant la guerre et sans leur
sacrifice et le sacrifice de ces
convois russes la guerre n'aurait jamais
été gagnée le seul regret de Dieu c'est que nous
ne parlons pas russe
je ne suis pas  un héros, vous savez,
je serai très heureux et je répondrai à toutes les
lettres que vous aimeriez chanter
[Musique]
mais nous venons juste de sortir et d'essayer, il y a toujours la
paix